what'd you think did you like the new
stadium i love the new stadium it would
have been even better if people were
there it's just so bizarre to have two
of the nicest stadiums we've ever seen
open with no one there right it's
it's still strange to see it although
i'm much more
used to it now than i was a week ago
agreed but it does have a good look i
like the cool like
uh i what are they that carbon flame
they have there to represent al davis
i love all the black seats certainly i
mean it really it's got a great look on
the outside you're right the last two
stadiums the last two weeks pretty
unbelievable and
way to go raiders what do you what is it
mike
are you more like pro raiders like whoa
i'm impressed by what they did or you a
little bit more right now as of tuesday
morning going whoa
i'm not exactly sure how good the saints
are exactly
i think it's a little bit of both yeah
and i think we get an answer
to each question this weekend because
the raiders go to new england to play
the patriots and the saints go home to
face the packers
so there's a chance both of those teams
are going to get blown off the field
come sunday
new england doing it to las vegas almost
said oakland
and the saints doing it to green bay
didn't almost say milwaukee
so uh that i think that's the reality
it's still to be determined because
we're so used to
to a reality in which the raiders
are mediocre at best and the saints are
mediocre at
very very worst on their worst possible
day
and i think that that that history
has me thinking well the saints without
michael thomas and well
they kind of got away from them and well
you know you're ready to go well
well well on both sides maybe the
reality is the raiders are
getting a lot better it helps to have
josh jacobs it helps to have derek carr
playing a hell of a lot better and it
helps to have josh jacobs to do that
and you know drew brees is 41 and father
time
continues to be undefeated yeah no i you
know it
you feel good about the raiders we
certainly saw positive things
last night and there are certain areas
where they match up
you know pretty well against the new
orleans saints their big offensive line
against that big defensive line of the
new orleans saiyans i mean
the raiders held their own at the very
least
really allowed them to keep being at
least consistent with the run game which
helped out the rest of their offense
yeah the saints had no michael thomas
but i did find myself there a little
wondering last night i'm not gonna lie
and i'm not trying to like rush to
judgment where i just went man
all right the saints don't look them
that impressive can't lie they didn't
look that impressive in week one either
and i know it's still the first two
weeks of the year but i did find myself
at some point i don't know what was
it third quarter there going man maybe i
don't know maybe this saints team has
passed its shelf life maybe it's on a
downward
it's going down and you know the last
three years yeah they were great but
how many more really great years do they
have in them and then you sit there and
watch the game and you go
yeah i know no michael thomas but you
said it drew brees is 41
and other than alvin kamara who can make
a big play on the offensive side of the
ball
and he's not necessarily a guy that's
going to go you know 60 70 yards or a
touchdown
in the pass game man it's work it's work
i mean it's it's got to be five yards at
a clip five yards six yards five
it's hard to drive in the nfl like that
always
and then you know mike i'd even throw it
over the defense and just go what's to
be excited about there right now who's a
difference maker
you know who's the guy that you look at
and go oh man they you got to stop him
or he's all over the place
they don't have that so i guess i'm a
little concerned or more concerned about
the saints than i thought i would be
after two weeks
what's amazing is the passing numbers
for the
saints far more spectacular than what
our eyeballs tell us watching the game
312 yards from drew brees over eight
yards per attempt
which suggests they're getting the ball
down the field
the ball was distributed to nine
different guys alvin kamara had 95 yards
on nine
catches and he had 79 yards rushing that
is if my math is correct and it rarely
is 174 yards from scrimmage and a couple
of touchdown runs
it looks like when you just scan through
the stats hey saints uh had a good night
well
they got off to a good start it was 17-7
it looked like here we go turn it off in
the third quarter
unless you want to sit around and watch
a lot of garbage time football
and then maybe it is that the defense
can't
take advantage of that opportunity to
deliver the kill
shot that would give the offense a
chance to go up 24-7
31-7 and then it's over yeah no i mean
i think the defense is a work in
progress at the very
best i mean that that the first thing is
we know why they were in the deviant
county sweepstakes we heard that we we
knew they made major play for him
well i think we've seen through two
weeks you know yeah
the the inability for guys in the front
seven to make a play make a difference
there
the corners and the secondary you like
it but i don't think that's up to par
either
marshawn lattimore for as talented as he
is he still gives up too many plays
so yeah it's unbuttoned and then when
you talk about the offensive side
of the ball yes statistics are good
they're always good with sean payton
but there's nothing there that moved the
needle when the game needed to be moved
when we started
we need we need passes now we need a
hundred we need a hundred yard quarter
now
not when it's 3117 and the other team is
or
what do i want to say yeah 3117 and
okay the other team's now in a little
bit of a place safe
prevent type defense and okay we get
down there and get a touchdown
in the fourth quarter and like rack up
stats like that it's a little too late
at that point and that's why you know
those are some bs stats there
there was just a sense of malaise almost
sleepwalking in the second half for the
saints they never could get the engine
started and it never felt like they had
a serious opportunity to come back and
win the game let's hear from
the two guys most responsible for the
saints offense since 2006 quarterback
drew brees and coach sean payton
are we totally in sync right now no
we're not we're not even close to what
we are capable of
not even close um we did some good
things tonight early on
but it just uh just wasn't enough for
the
the few opportunities we had we need to
take better advantage of that
you got to credit las vegas you know
those guys did a great job they got in
and out of plays
versus our coverage looks um
you know and one by one they made the
plays when they needed to especially
especially in the last half of that game
you know third quarter fourth quarter
uh our third down numbers were poor and
and we didn't do a good job of stopping
one of their better players
you know it's funny anytime i see
someone wearing a shirt like drew brees
i start running the number through my
memory bank what is the significance is
it a social justice statement
what is something i'm missing 149 it's
michael thomas that might
it's michael thomas's reception total
last year and it was fitting
that drew brees wore that shirt last
night because he could have used michael
thomas
i wonder if that's his subtle way of
saying don't blame me we'd have won the
game if michael thomas
didn't have an ankle injury well it does
seem a little weird
and that was the concern of not having
michael thomas he's you know first off
he's a talented football player we know
that
then he fits in with what how sean
payton wants to call offensive
football and even more importantly
he fits into drew brees at 41 who
you know here we are we're discussing
drew brees's inability to throw the ball
down the field or outside the numbers
through two weeks is an issue
it's an issue and then when you don't
have a guy like michael thomas
who lives and kills like
nfl football weekly with intermediate to
short passes
for the most part yeah that was a big
part of their offense missing
but that that to me is is this the
silver lining of the game in itself
just play makers for that that saints
team
and you know up 17 to seven right mike
got the ball and got a wide open
um jared cook on the left sideline
running like a corner route
ball gets kind of thrown high and above
them and it was like the game was never
the same
from that point on the raiders started
to move the ball
a little bit the same way the saints do
just picking you apart five
six seven yards at a time but you sit
there and you start to go
well damn the raiders might have a few
more difference makers on the offensive
side of the ball than the saints when it
comes down to it
i mean darren waller everybody saw last
night he's in that conversation
with kelsey and and george kittle and
then
we saw josh jacobs and things like that
too so they were able to create
create enough plays with their
playmakers and that similar sean payton
style of offense with john gruden where
yeah
little inside slant little throw to the
back out of the back field
all of those type of things were very
effective on the saints all night long
michael thomas wasn't there but he was
watching the game and
it would have been better for him to
just go ahead and self-report himself
to old takes exposed instead of tweeting
might get ugly fast lol and then
deleting it all they still get you even
if you don't self-report
the freezing cold takes account they're
gonna get you it's always better
to self report yourself but yeah michael
thomas might get ugly fast lol
no it got ugly slow michael the raiders
ended up coming back obviously as we
know at this point unless michael turned
it off and went to bed
and the raiders got it done it should
make thomas feel good at some level like
you want your team to win
you want your team to rack up as many
wins as possible but it is nice to know
at some level
they really do miss me well yeah it is
nice i'm sure
yes but but he realized that before how
important he was
yeah does this you know you know
honestly it confirms that he knows he's
a big part of this offense and they're
not as good
but he's not happy that's for sure
because of course he's trying to win a
super bowl too this is a team that's got
super bowl on their mind and that's all
there is to it
and we've seen them the last few years
that's where like i i go like let's pump
the brakes a little
even though i don't like the way the
saints have looked they have
traditionally through the last few years
been a slow
starting football team so like drew
brees says
maybe this is the early we're just in
the early stages they can get a lot
better
but i do think there's a few things that
concern me right now and as we sit here
yeah one and one that's good they're
certainly not in like the doghouse or
anything but
week one we thought the offense looked
crappy against the buccaneers too
it was crappy and then the defense had
moments of making a few plays but not
looking great either so
uh the saints are kind of like to be
determined in my mind right now
as the great larry king once said to
jerry seinfeld
sometimes shows go down and as seinfeld
said sometimes people do
as well drew brees last night facing the
question of whether
he is seeing his skills and his career
deteriorate
you know it's a popular narrative
already from a lot of analysts that
they're
concerned we're seeing a sharp decline
from your performance and some stats
that
you know your air yards are the shortest
through two games of any quarterback in
more than a decade
what would you say to counter the
narrative that that you don't feel like
you're starting this season um showing
decline
well we uh my job is to execute the
offense
right and so um i'll uh
i think i've i've always evaluated
myself on being
a great decision maker and so at the end
of the day
i'm gonna throw the ball to the open guy
move the ball down the field
score points help us win football games
you know so that's my job
my job is not to have the most care
yards
um or throw the ball down the field the
most or
anything like that now my jobs help us
win my job's help
put everybody around me in the best
position to succeed and
that's all i'm focused on you know a lot
of football players would like to become
actors i think drew brees has the chops
because he was pissed at that question
chris
you see it as it was being asked and he
thought about
maybe he was watching the show yesterday
he thought about
the bill belichick 22 second just don't
say anything
and they'll move on to the next question
no i don't think drew would do that
i'm sure yeah i'm sure he wanted to be
like you know
hey fu i got we got other issues on the
offense it's not me
anything like that listen bottom line is
like air yards for drew brees have never
been very high i mean even
even in years where he was having huge
statistical years he was always towards
towards the bottom of these especially
these last few years towards the bottom
of error-intended yards
as far as the ball traveling in the air
but it's more than that through the
first two games
you heard brian gracie allude to it
early in the game last night
there on monday night football talking
about last week he was off
we saw balls that you know went high
that fell
short of the target we saw it again last
night
i mean that's just the thing that and
it's not like we're seeing balls that
fall
short of the target that are like 25
yard out routes
we're seeing eight yard throws at the
ankles we're seeing an interception down
the middle that's
six feet short of the target uh we're
seeing
third downs where he has to move in the
pocket and there's a guy open over the
middle and the ball just hangs in the
air forever
and a linebacker can run and close down
and knock it down and not get the
completion
so i think that's the thing that's more
concerning i don't care about
necessarily the intended air yards
but it's the way it also looks and
that's to where i just questioned
man it's just it's hard work i i
i know it's drew brees and sean payton
and they're the kings execution
but to just think you're going to go on
10 and 12 play 80 yard drives
game after game after game and do that
it's just that's a lot to ask of your
whole football team and
if you make one mistake you know the
drive gets messed up and
nothing's the same yeah that's the thing
about their offense and that's why when
they were down
14 points late in the game you said
there's no
chance how do you how you don't have
the kind of offense that's going to
consistently give you
25 and 30 yards per play when you need
it the most
it's more hoping that you pop something
right on a short pass that that goes
that far
but at that point of the game when
they're keeping everything in front of
them
and that's why i was surprised frankly
that that late in the game that's what
the raiders were doing because you don't
have to do that you don't have to stay
back you're playing into the saints
offense if you stay back
go ahead and be aggressive and force him
to throw it over the top because he's
not gonna do it no so
he's not but you know that scares
coaches always right you just
oh man here goes alvin kamara one on one
out of the back field and our guy trips
and falls and then it's a white you know
that that that's but you're right
you're right in your thought though like
you don't need to back off and prevent
defense
similar to like maybe other quarterbacks
you could probably push the envelope a
little bit with the saints and breeze
because of the things you're mentioning
okay so how about this yeah
and we're not starting the conversation
we're just raising the question of at
what point the conversation becomes a
conversation
and i don't think it does all year long
jameis winston
signed as a free agent after the
buccaneers moved on the only guy on the
entire
active roster in the first two weeks who
didn't play for the saints
taysom hill who got a big contract and
it looks like the contract that was
given to taysom hill was more about
making the down payment on keeping him
around right not using him more
in fact you can make the argument they
need to use them more
well that they need to use him more
generally
he had 14 offensive snaps last night
nine snaps on special teams they are
using him much more sparingly on special
teams
which tells me that when you consider
both ends of it yeah
they're protecting him in the event that
they need him
you're right and they're either going to
need him because of injury
or because sean payton's going to get to
a point where he says
sorry drew it's not working and again i
don't think
it gets to that point this year i think
a lot's got to go haywire yeah for that
to happen
but it doesn't make sense to pay taysom
hill all that money and then
he has two rushes for eight yards zero
catches and zero passes last night
i was alarmed that there wasn't even a
single pass attempt for taysom hill last
night
so we saw i thought the best guy on the
field for the saints and maybe the best
guy on the field for either team
in the wild card playoff loss to
minnesota that's what
sparked the conversation about what's
his future and the saints paid him the
big contract 21 million over two years
with 16 million guaranteed
and now they're they're protecting him
yeah and it doesn't make
sense unless they're protecting him in
the event
that number seven not number nine is
going to be playing quarterback at some
point before the end of the year
again i don't think it should happen i
don't think it will happen no i'm with
you but there's got to be an explanation
for all of a sudden taysom hill not
being used
on special teams as much as he was he
played 84 of the snaps on special teams
in the playoff game
19 last night something's going on there
with taysom hill
where they are keeping him in a in a not
a full-blown bubble wrap
yeah just kind of a coating of
protective plastic yeah right now he's
just the guy that the other team has to
prepare for
like oh we got to prepare for some of
these taste some hill plays but you're
not gonna really see them that much
but it's a pain in our butt so yeah
we'll get ready and we don't want to get
burned by it but
yeah he's not a part of the flow of the
offense by any stretch of the
imagination like we've seen over the
last two years
where he's been a great weapon and been
that guy mike that we're just talking
about where we say there's a lack of the
saints offense
he's been that guy to create big plays
and bring a little energy to the offense
whether it's the design runs and him
running over people or ripping off an 8
or 10 yard gain
it does add juice to their offense and a
little bit of explosive element
or him setting up to throw deep passes
which also sometimes leads to him then
scrambling and getting a 10
15 yard scramble that also is there you
know on the verge of an explosive type
play
but i think mike you hit it i think it's
like bubble wrap
because he's he they view him as the
future to a degree
and i think they're stuck in between
right now because yeah if something did
happen to drew brees i i think we both
get the sense that it would not be
jameis winston this year like it was
teddy bridgewater last year
that it would be taysom hill that it's
finally come time to groom him
for the next step and i guess that's why
they're saving them but
you know like you're saying when they've
been at their best
that on the offensive side of the ball
he's a part of it and they're special
teams and that's when they put a lot of
pressure on you in all three phases of
their football team
and here's the thing last night was by
no means a statement game by the raiders
against the saints it was just one of
those where we are still undecided about
what we saw and what it means that's
right
now the saints have to pack up in las
vegas
go back to new orleans on a short week
and get ready for the packers to come to
town
on sunday night football wow where
everyone's going to be watching
that's where the statement game could
happen that's where the wheels could
come off
that's where the conversation we're
having today
all of a sudden by next monday chris
that conversation could be much more
widespread right so
what we're doing is we're just planting
a flag
at the possibility that on sunday night
and
we always want a close exciting game
down to the wire on sunday night
football on nbc we want every game to be
close and exciting but especially the
ones on our network
but if it gets ugly on sunday night yeah
and and and think about it oh aaron
rodgers going into another loud stadium
that isn't going to be loud at all
because no fans are going to be there
gets neutralized and and the way he's
been playing and they think devante
adams will be good to go
he left the third quarter of sunday's
win over detroit with a hamstring injury
i don't want to turn this into a
full-blown preview for sunday night
football but my point is this
if the packers do to the saints what the
packers
did to the vikings and what the packers
did to the lions only the fourth team in
nfl history to score more than 80 points
and gain more than a thousand yards in
the first two games of the season
if they make that 120 and 1500 that's
when the conversation is going to be a
lot louder about are the saints in
decline chris yeah
i mean agreed you're right i mean on
that spotlight
rogers there's breeze you know it's it's
highly likely your course you're gonna
see right now green bay you're gonna see
rogers pushing the ball down the field
and that'll even
shine a spotlight more on drew brees
to go wait where's his plays like that
so
uh it'll be interesting to see and i
think that's why
you know it's why i'm a little concerned
too just because
just from what we've seen from the
raiders in two weeks
i i i don't the raiders the raiders
defense is not good
i think that's why i'm concerned i mean
we saw last night they had a hard time
tackling alvin kamara in the backfield i
mean they could have gave the ball to
him more
that would be one thing i'd say to sean
payton like why didn't you just
hand him the ball more in the backfield
like the true run game
but i mean teddy bridgewater and the
carolina panthers
diced up the raiders and as we saw
after like those first two series
with the new orleans saints and like
they run out of
okay sean payton here's like the plays i
really love going in the game these are
our game plan plays we're gonna
gash them with that okay now we've that
that that part of our game plans off
ooh they've made some adjustments now
now what do we go to they're they were
unable to make plays
that's just the simple fact of the
matter against the defense that
i think everybody would agree that has
no play makers none
i mean they're young and inexperienced
in the secondary they blow coverages
there's nobody to talk about in the
front four that's like really special
there
you know same thing linebackers i got
corey littleton but that's about it i
think that's where i get concerned about
the saints going
man that raiders defense young and
experienced
not the soundest of schemes and they
still
went basically two and a half quarters
of struggling to move the ball i think
that's what
probably bothered me more than anything
okay all the raiders fans out there are
saying i know you idiots you're 24
minutes into the program and you've been
obsessed with the saints well
there's a method to the madness although
there isn't this is just my story and
i'm sticking to it
it's 4 24 a.m in
nevada right now live right so we gave
john gruden a chance to get to the
office
for the rear it's 7 24 a.m
in nevada and in california where the
concentration of raiders fans are
we're giving you folks a chance to wake
up before we begin to praise the team
that is
surprisingly two-and-oh the one team
that is matching the kansas city chiefs
and just think of that well if the
chiefs hadn't beaten the chargers they'd
be two-and-oh but either way
the raiders are two-and-oh tied atop the
afc west and they deserve the praise for
what they did
last night holding serve at the
christening
of the giant roomba in the desert they
get it done
and you have to give them credit and
let's hear from the head coach of the
team that got it done and the
quarterback who got it done
that's right and derek carr
well for the last couple weeks we've
been pretty good
taking care of the ball talking no
turnovers converting on third down
having some balance and winning the time
of possession and when you can
win the time of possession and keep
brees and sean payton over there
together on the sideline
you have a chance but we knew it was
going to be a 15-round fight here
tonight we knew the saints
were going to give us everything that we
had and certainly the third down
conversion was big tonight
i'm tired of talking you know if some
some people can probably hear it in my
voice sometimes
um you know it's nice you know it's nice
to go out and be 2-0 it's nice to play
against
the the saints the world champions you
know
top whatever defense top whatever
offense the special teams units one of
the best in league
and get a win i mean that feels good you
know it's a good statement monday night
all that but
just like i told the guys after the game
when we brought it up i said
jobs job's not done you know um
if we want to you know be all excited
and you know
you know feel good about ourselves
because people are saying nice things
now
and all that kind of stuff then we're
gonna go to the patriots on a short week
and lose
now you could go to the patriots on a
short we can lose anyway i mean look i'm
i'm not ready to christen the raiders as
a team that's ready to go three and no
now you wanna get everybody's attention
you go to foxboro and you beat the
patriots i just don't see enough from
this raiders team
to think that they're going to be able
to do it they should just be happy
they're 2-0 and keep grinding one week
at a time and go in there with them
of course they're going in there with
the mindset they're going to try to win
right you may win
you may win but even if you lose you're
going to grow as a team you're going to
learn more about yourself you're going
to figure out what you need to address
to improve
so you can win more games remember seven
playoff spots available
you start two-and-oh you're in and we
always after the second week we start
hearing all the stats about the teams to
go two and oh x percent of them make it
to the playoffs and no one two x percent
done
well it's all going to change this year
because there's another spot so you
start two and oh
you're already ahead of the game for at
a minimum wild card number three
so good news for the raiders but uh look
they've got some
geez patriots bills chiefs buccaneers
two and oh could become two and four
really quickly chris
yes it can it definitely can well we'll
say this and you're right i'm not ready
to crown the las vegas raiders or
anything like that
but they are 2-0 they won a game in week
two that we did not expect them to win
nobody picked them right
so they do that and this is the one
thing i'll say
about my ex-coach and john gruden and
everything there
his teams are tough they were tough as
hell last year
they're still in the early stages of
like rebuilding this football team
they're young throughout their roster
but man i mean they bring it to you you
know we talk about jon gruden and you
know west right slot 72 z bingo you
split or scattered a west right slot f
left 372 why sticks espot
but he's old school and he wants to run
the football and that's the one thing he
does with this football team is he
creates an attitude where their
offensive line it's big it's mean
and it blows people off the line of
scrimmage that always gives them a
fighting chance and even games where
they're over matched or are not the
better team on the football field
so that's been big and then we to give
derek carr credit i mean derek carr is
playing really good football
would were there a few plays last night
that we we saw mike and
and you know my old teammate brian
griese pointed out a few times like hey
i wish he would have thrown the ball
down the field here or been a little bit
more aggressive
without a doubt still a work in progress
there
but damn does he execute the offense and
damn
does he put every short throw right on
the money to where the guy like a darren
waller
he could always run after the catch he
could always running through the arm
tackle
or stop on a dime to make a guy go by so
he can make him miss
that's where he's he's really great that
way i mean i wish he was more aggressive
but
he's playing the damn position pretty
damn good right now
what you always say about the john
gruden offense it's a ferrari he
entrusts you with the keys and he
doesn't want you to wreck it or even
scratch the paint right
last night derek carr did not record or
scratch the paint the thing is though
he also wants the quarterback to know
when to put the pedal to the metal
and let it fly and see how fast he can
get it going and that's where derek carr
still continues to be hesitant
when you have darren waller you know how
about darren waller 12 catches 103 yards
and a touchdown it's actually one catch
short of his career high at 13 last year
against the vikings but darren waller
quickly becoming one of the best
tight ends in the nfl we did our best
tight ends draft other than george kiddo
and travis kelsey maybe it should have
been other than
kittle kelsey and waller well yeah i
think i was glad
i'm pretty sure he was our first pick or
my first pick though
because he is a guy that you know the
the national media normal you know day
fans who just turn on football oh hey a
game's on i don't think they know him
yet
so he we we had to draft him or put him
in the draft but you're right he's in
the class of those guys
i mean he's a pretty good run blocker
and he is phenomenal
in the past game as you saw and gruden
is amazing
at figuring out how to get the tight end
the football he really is especially a
big tight end like that mike because he
can also like
gruden's got yeah knows how to use the
tight end
but has all those michael thomas slot
plays too
to where a tight end like darren waller
can do all that stuff those inside
slants and
different routes to like expose
underneath linebacker coverage and stuff
he he's amazing that way and such he's
such a big body
he just catches the ball and people fall
off him or he runs away from you
and of that size to be that big and run
the way he does uh he's he's pretty
special they were brilliant last year
in getting out in front of that contract
and giving him 9 million a year
early on in the year last year because
he exploded and he could sit here this
year and probably have asked for
to be the highest paid tight end in
football other than george kittle and
probably would have been able to justify
that
i'm amazed by the stats generated by
josh jacobs i thought he did a lot
better than 88 yards yeah 27 carries 3.3
yards per carry you take out his long
run
of 14. he had 2.8 yards per carry on 26
carries chris i thought he was grinding
it out a lot more than that well he was
grinding it out you know
he was it's not easy sledding as we've
talked about for
like the last two years with the saints
they got a lot of big bodies on that
defensive line
i think the fact that you're allowed
you're capable of getting two three four
yard type runs
that's almost a win against the saints
because they're used to you like oh you
run on first down
oh it's second and ten you went nowhere
that's kind of the way
the way they play football and you know
too mike
you're you're right when i first saw the
stats i looked at it and i went it just
seemed like he had a better day
but i think in the big moments you know
first down
runs that was big and the carries got a
little watered down
by a few goal line situations and short
yardage situations where
you know hey we all knew he was running
up the middle and he he had three or
four carries where he you know barely
got to the line of scrimmage or only got
a yard in those goal line situations of
course that is always
always makes the numbers look uglier too
still had 30 touches for the night so
you know it's
it's the kind of thing that running
backs love until they realize they're
only playing four or five years because
their bodies have been banged up
there also were a couple of losses and
trey hendrickson blew him up in the
backfield on one of them it was it was a
great play for henderson because it was
one play after a a roughing the passer
call on hendrickson he put his hand up
and his hand
hit the helmet of derrick carr right and
the raiders got 15 yards and then on the
next play hendrickson blew up
josh jacobs uh to atone for it a little
bit but jacob's
you know he's what john gruden needed
one of the three first round picks last
year he was in the conversation for
offensive rookie of the year but for
kyle murray he would have been
and now he's in a position where he's
he's piling up the yards
even if it wasn't as many last night as
we thought it would be
and and it gives the offense what it
needs that big presence in the running
game that sets
up the passing game no doubt it protects
a defense that we know is not that
talented it keeps the offense on the
field
chewing up the clock like john gruden
said
you know it it kept drew brees and sean
payton on the sideline that's the best
defense for their football team
gruden knows his defense is young and
and still a work in progress
so that's why he continues to do that
and that's where jacobs is special mike
because
you know he's he's he can be a little
bit of that alvin kamara out of the
backfield type guy and you go oh wow
look at those moves but
he's got a true you know workhorse
type mentality when he's a runner like
where it's like
damn i mean he just grinded it in there
like derrick henry and just putting his
head down and smashing in there and
making those type of runs too
very interesting combination but gruden
loves to run the football i think it's
one thing that's always kind of been
underrated as far as the talk aspect of
what gruden brings to the football team
that physicality that offensive line it
helps them control the game in a lot of
ways and it helps out their short
passing game too
because you're you're worried about
stopping that run and packing in the box
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports